Amigos, Camboya es de todo menos un país
cualquiera.
A sus espalda acarrea años tan duros que
hicieron de este lugar uno de los países
más pobres y con peores perspectivas de futuro
de todo el sudeste asiático.
Situado entre dos potencias económicas y
demográficas emergentes, Vietnam y Tailandia,
este pequeño país de menos de 16 millones
de habitantes tiene en su haber una de las
historias más terribles, crueles y despiadadas
de todo el continente y, por qué no decirlo
también, de todo el planeta.
(En 1975 el Partido Comunista de Camboya tomó
el poder. Durante los siguientes 4 años,
hasta su caído en 1979, los jemeres rojos
- que era como se conocía a los miembros
del partido - perpetraron uno de los peores
genocidios que ha conocido la humanidad.
Durante la existencia de Kampuchea Democrática,
el nombre del estado regido por los Jemeres
Rojos, entre un millón y medio y tres millones
de personas perdieron la vida como consecuencia
de sus políticas. Un cuarto de la población
de todo el país. ¡En tan solo 4 años!
La persecución a la disidencia política
y a las minorías raciales y religiosas constituyeron
la mayor parte de esta escalofriante cifra.)
Y es que amigos, allí no se salvaba nadie.
Musulmanes, cristianos, budistas, personas
de una u otra etnia, cualquiera que el gobierno
considerase enemigo de la revolución era
objetivo de la “purga”.
[Vamos, sí, que los Jemeres Rojos estaban
tremendamente chiflados.]
Y claro, todo esto hizo que las perspectivas
de desarrollo de Camboya se vieran truncadas
durante un montón de años porque... ¿Cómo
te recuperas de semejante bestialidad?
Como podéis imaginar no es nada, pero que
nada fácil.
Y sí, precisamente de eso os vamos a hablar
hoy en este vídeo, de cómo ha cambiado Camboya
desde el fin del comunismo en el terreno económico
y también político,
Y también sobre qué podemos esperar en el
futuro de este pequeño país asiático localizado
en una de las zonas con más potencial y futuro
de todo el mundo.
Atentos.
(UNA ECONOMÍA 100% DEPENDIENTE)
Amigos, Camboya ha vivido en los últimos
años un crecimiento económico brutal, exponencial.
Entre 1997 y 2017, el PIB ha crecido cada
año una media del 7,7%. El PIB per cápita
se ha multiplicado por más de tres.
Son números de bandera, pero… ¿En qué
se ha traducido exactamente semejante desarrollo?
Pues, por ejemplo, todo este enorme crecimiento
económico ha hecho que la población que
vive bajo el umbral de la pobreza se haya
reducido de aproximadamente el 50 a poco más
del 13%.
Y claro, con estos números pensaréis…¡Vaya!
Parece que en Camboya las cosas van muy bien….¿No?
Pues, sí… y no.
Lo cierto es que en estos momentos el país
vive - por así decirlo - una gran incertidumbre.
Se encuentra entre dos aguas, entre China
y los actores occidentales - Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea.
Pero, vayamos por partes.
Ya hemos visto el enorme crecimiento de la
economía camboyana durante las últimas dos
décadas, así que la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es,
¿Qué ofrece exactamente Camboya? ¿En qué
se basa su modelo económico?
(Pues, amigos, la respuesta aquí es simple:
industria textil y turismo.
La potente industria textil camboyana supone
aproximadamente el 80% de las exportaciones
del país y emplea a más de 700.000 personas.
Con mucha diferencia esta industria es el
motor del país y la primera fuente de ingresos
de buena parte de las familias camboyanas.)
Por cierto, un apunte, Camboya tiene una característica
que está dificultado mucho su desarrollo
y que puede suponer un enorme problema para
su futuro. Fijaos.
(Camboya sigue siendo mayoritariamente un
país rural. Menos del 25% de la población
vive en las ciudades, lo que lo sitúa como
uno de los países menos urbanizados del planeta.
Para que os hagáis una idea de lo que significa
esta cifra, su vecino Laos alcanza ya casi
el 40%.
En estas condiciones el acceso y la prestación
de servicios educativos resulta algo muy caro
y difícil de gestionar. La mayoría de los
colegios rurales no tienen libros ni conexión
a internet, y la gente sigue mirando al campo
como forma de vida. Esto explica porque aproximadamente
el 20% de la población adulta es analfabeta.)
Pero, amigos, no nos desviemos. Gran parte
del despegue de económico de Camboya ha tenido
otro protagonista, un protagonista que ha
llegado con un enooorme fajo de billetes y
ladrillos bajo el brazo.
Pero, ¿Queréis saber quién se esconde detrás
de esta enorme lluvia de inversiones?
(China, China lleva años invirtiendo cientos
de millones de dólares en infraestructuras
y también en el sector de la construcción,
de la promoción inmobiliaria.
Ahora en Camboya es muy común ver paisajes
llenos de grúas, e imponentes edificios y
rascacielos en construcción.
Tan solo en los últimos dos años se han
aprobado cerca de 6.000 proyectos de construcción
valorados en más de 11.000 millones de dólares.
Y sí, amigos, la mayor parte de los compradores
en este nuevo y prometedor mercado inmobiliario
vienen de China. Normalmente entre el 50 y
el 80% de los inmuebles de las promociones
inmobiliarias más lujosas de la capital,
Nom Pen, son adquiridos por chinos.)
Pero, un momento, ¿A qué responde semejante
fervor?¿Es que los chinos se vuelven locos
por Camboya?
Pues… puede ser, pero hay otra razón: la
escasa supervisión que este país hace sobre
la procedencia del dinero así como sus laxas
regulaciones, han hecho que muchos millonarios
chinos hayan visto en Camboya un refugio para
su dinero. Ya sabéis, por si se tuercen las
cosas en China.
Pero, claro toda moneda tiene dos caras y
en este historia no iba a ser diferente.
Hasta ahora hemos visto la mejor cara, pero,
¿qué ocurre con la otra?
(HUN SEN, CHINA Y LA MUERTE DE LA DEMOCRACIA)
Hasta ahora os hemos hablado de qué está
pasando en la economía de Camboya pero, no,
no podemos olvidarnos de Hun Sen, primer ministro
del país y protagonista absoluto de la actualidad
camboyana.
(Hun Sen fue uno de los principales opositores
al régimen maoísta de los Jémeres Rojos
y alcanzó el poder en 1979 con la invasión
vietnamita que puso fin a la Kampuchea Democrática
y al horror de los jémeres liderados por
Pol Pot.
Desde entonces, Hun Sen lleva gobernando el
país convirtiéndose en el gobernante que
más tiempo lleva en el poder tan solo por
detrás del guineano Teodoro Obiang.)
Umm… A simple vista el que un gobernante
lleve tantísimo tiempo en el poder no pinta
nada, pero nada bien, ¿no os parece?
Pues… Veréis, en 1993 Hun Sen aprobó una
nueva Constitución que, al menos sobre el
papel, democratizaría el país convirtiéndolo
en una monarquía constitucional con un sistema
multipartidista para elegir democráticamente
al Primer Ministro.
Sin embargo, han pasado 26 años y de la Democracia
ni rastro.
La Constitución existe pero no hay oposición
porque de facto el propio régimen no lo permite.
Y en los últimos años la cosa ha ido a peor.
(En las elecciones locales de junio de 2017,
el partido opositor Rescate Nacional de Camboya
logró un importante apoyo popular. Sin embargo
su alegría iba a durar poco. El Tribunal
Supremo, controlado por el Primer Ministro,
ordenó en noviembre de ese mismo la disolución
del partido opositor y el encarcelamiento
de su lider, Kem Sokha.
¿La excusa? Pues la de siempre en estos casos…
Se acusó a la oposición de estar planeando
un alzamiento. Tras la ilegalización de la
oposición y el encarcelamiento de Sokha que
llevó a otros líderes opositores al exilio,
el régimen de Hun Sen demostró que las libertades
políticas que promulga la Constitución de
1993 fueron, a la hora de la verdad, simplemente
cosméticas.)
Pero, amigos, semejante atropello a la democracia
y a las libertades políticas iba a tener
consecuencias.
(La Cámara de Representantes de Estados Unidos
aprueba un paquete de sanciones contra altos
funcionarios de Camboya. Voice of America)
(La UE inicia el proceso para golpear a Camboya
con sanciones comerciales. Reuters)
Y, amigos, es esto último lo que más daño
puede hacerle a Camboya: las sanciones comerciales
de la Unión Europea.
Aunque en realidad no se trata de sanciones,
sino de la retirada de Camboya del programa
europeo “Todo salvo Armas”, un programa
que beneficia a los países más pobres dándoles
acceso al mercado europeo mediante la exención
de aranceles, lo cual ha ayudado enormemente
al desarrollo de la industria textil camboyana.
Pero claro, para poder aprovecharse de estas
ventajas comerciales hay ciertas condiciones,
y una de ellas es que se aseguren los derechos
humanos y las libertades políticas y democráticas.
(Y es precisamente por la violación de Hun
Sen de estos principios que la UE se encuentra
inmersa en pleno proceso de expulsión de
Camboya de esta iniciativa, lo que puede poner
en peligro buena parte de la producción textil,
la principal fuente de ingresos camboyana,
cuyas exportaciones a la Unión Europea suponen
unos 6.000 millones de dólares, alrededor
del 40% de las exportaciones totales del país.
Ahí es nada.)
Y claro, ante semejante amenaza, lo lógico
es que Hun Sen diera marcha atrás, ¿no creéis?
Pues… no, nada más lejos de la realidad.
Hun Sen no solo se reafirma sino que culpa
a la Unión Europea de entrometerse en asuntos
internos.
Pero… esperad un momento. Porque si a Hun
Sen parece que le dan igual las sanciones
y este jaque a la economía camboyana, ¿estará
entonces el Primer Ministro condenando al
país al desastre?
Bueno… podríamos pensar que sí, pero la
realidad es algo más complicada.
Lo que Hun Sen tiene realmente en mente es
reducir la dependencia de Occidente girando
hacia China.
Es más, las relaciones con Pekín son tan
buenas que el apoyo es mutuo.
Veréis, mientras China hunta al régimen
camboyano con ayudas e inversiones, Camboya
apoya a China en las resoluciones de la ASEAN
que condenan la expansión militar y territorial
de Pekín en el mar de la China Meridional.
Y esperad un momento porque esto no acaba
aquí. Atentos.
(China reportedly signs secret deal to station
troops in Cambodia. The Guardian)
(Según informes, China firma un acuerdo secreto
para estacionar tropas en Camboya. The Guardian)
Sí sí, habéis oído bien. Hay importantes
indicios de que China podría terminar abriendo
una base militar en Camboya. Una nueva base
militar china en el extranjero. Veremos cómo
acaba.
Con todo esto amigos hay algo claro… Hun
Sen se ha convertido en un hombre de Pekín,
y está dando la espalda a Occidente, es el
último jugador en hacerlo.
Pero ahora turno para ti… ¿Qué os parece
que China esté apalancando su poder en el
Sudeste Asiático a base de talonario incluso
a costa de perjudicar las libertades políticas?
¿Debería Hun Sen retractarse y ser más
neutral entre Occidente y China?
Cuéntanos qué te parece en esta encuesta
y dejanos también tus comentarios aquí abajo
y, si te ha gustado este vídeo, no olvides
darle like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik para
estar al tanto de todas nuestras novedades.
¡Un saludo y hasta al próxima!